this next story takes us to jakarta
where a group of young professionals are
embodying what it means to be part of
the so-called solidarity economy
[Music]
this mega city has been hard hit by the
pandemic jakarta capital of indonesia
and southeast asia's fastest growing
internet economy
in its darkest hour one man a hobby
musician turned this to his advantage
lodi andrean teamed up with some friends
to stand strong in the face of the
pandemic
we didn't know how long this will last
it wasn't clear what disease this was
and we didn't know when it will end so
from there actually from that
uncertainty we decided to do something
and this is what he came up with
scrolling her instagram account marita
putri who had just lost her job in an
advertising agency discovered bagirata
an initiative that promised financial
aid without red tape
actually i had no income other than
selling breakfast
my husband used to work but he was laid
off too in the pandemic
so to feed the family i tried to sign up
for this platform baguirata
to have at least some funds to keep my
breakfast business going
model work
bhagirata is a wealth distribution
platform where the name reflects the aim
it translates to equal share because
this is what lodi andrean felt was
needed most in the lockdown
with four friends the 29 year old
designer founded the non-profit
organization
bugirata is a cross-subsidy platform for
the people who are affected by the
pandemic
especially in formal workers who don't
get government assistance or who don't
get help from their offices and
freelancers
so the platform itself allows people who
can help financially to get in contact
with people who need help
likewise the latter can say what they
need
more than 4 000 people from all over
indonesia have already received money
through bhagirata
the founders have distributed around 90
000 euros in donations the key to
success was that andrean took advantage
of an existing digital infrastructure
that had been built up in indonesia in
recent years he programmed bhagirata as
a direct transfer system where the money
doesn't have to go through their hands
donors can directly send funds to
beneficiaries through their e-wallet
almost everybody here uses apps like ovo
gopay or dana and mobile phones are
affordable the advertisement also takes
place online
what turned out to be more time
consuming however was the verification
process the team wanted to make sure
that people didn't register twice
moreover they wanted to only help people
hit by the pandemic
so what we do is actually a full
feasibility assessment
we check if the profession of the person
applying is really affected
is he or she a business owner or an
employee
and of course was the business disrupted
by the pandemic or are there other
reasons like a drop in demand it's a
time consuming procedure for five people
particularly after hours but for donors
like hariya rivani this is extremely
important the creative director
regularly uses the platform to help
people in need
it's definitely better
meaning that the concept of bhagiratha
is clearly better than what the
government has to offer
for one thing i can list the people i
want to support and i also have more
confidence in the spirit of the people
in bhagirata
the spirit of solidarity is great and
there is no other interest because they
really want to help each other and in my
opinion that's a significant thing
indeed
rivani feels privileged to be able to
work from home if another wave builds up
like right now with omicron
so he is happy to share some of his
money he also appreciates that via the
app he can remain anonymous while still
knowing who will receive his money
actually we're not all in the same boat
because there's so many people who
really need help
so it's as simple as that i look at
people's profile i see for example what
kind of reason he or she has to apply
then i check their background a bit
those kind of things well i'm not that
picky
initially bugirata was planned as a
short-term project three months at most
that was two years ago
now we still stick with it when the
pandemic is over and mobility returns to
normal and the economy starts to improve
we will close this platform however the
pandemic is still ongoing therefore
bhagiratha will probably continue to
help hundreds of people
marretta putri no longer needs the
platform at least for now her husband
found a new job and the 28 year old
mother of two is now optimistic that the
country's economy will recover too
she puts her trust in the official
booster campaign for which she'll
register with what else
her smartphone
we're joined by dw's asia pacific bureau
chief georg matas he's also the author
of that report
georg you follow the people we saw in
the story there for months what's the
situation like now for indonesians
effectively the situation right now is
that the economy here has practically
bounced back from the
from the time in summer last year when
indonesia was hard hit by the delta wave
now it's a bit of an ironical situation
here that we still see parts of the
economy opening up and parts of the
economy preparing for a potential
omicron wave to come the key difference
this time however is that the
vaccination campaign has been uh quite
successful 85 percent of people in
indonesia some 200 million people
eligible for vaccinations
have received their first dose 58 have
received the second dose and one percent
the booster and that will be key uh that
is part of the strategy of the
government where basically the
government puts its hope in
that this time they do not have to lock
down the economy as much and
place their hope into the effectiveness
of of this booster
now that's what the government is doing
but this story is an example of the
solidarity economy at work essentially
of people helping each other out does
that mean they don't think the
government is doing enough
i would say it's an example of of the
spirit that you have in indonesia that
people really reach out to help each
other to be fair when it comes to the
government one has to say that it's
facing huge challenges if you lock down
an economy like indonesia that creates
enormous problems and so the government
has put out some stimulus packages uh
some packages to deal with the health
sector in fact for this year alone uh 30
million 30 billion euros have been
earmarked for various projects uh a lot
of that will go into the health sector
but there is some controversy now
whether some of that money will is also
uh planned to be used for the
moving of the capital of jakarta to a
different island and that is what some
people reject because they say that the
problems we we have right now are
already so big
now you cover the asia pacific area for
us and a china slowdown is expected to
impact the wider region how big of a
concern is this where you are
look with indonesia you have the biggest
coal exporter with china you have the
biggest coal importer worldwide so they
do make a happy couple if things go well
if things don't go well you immediately
feel the
results here in indonesia in 2020 you
already had problems in the electric
industry uh when covet was raging in
china in 2021 the country was hard hit
because uh there was a huge drop in uh
in exports uh to uh china
china being the biggest uh exporting
destination for indonesia
and so uh pretty much everyone is
expecting that this will have an impact
on the relationship and now as well
particularly at a time when uh for
instance with nickel there's a lot of
corporations going on to be prepared for
the battery industry with cars
on the other hand a number of
indonesians have already set out that
they place also their hopes into the u.s
market because the u.s is keen to
increase its relations
with china with rather with indonesia in
order to decrease the influence of china
in this region
georg matas he's our asia pacific bureau
chief thank you very much for your time
today